I was born in the Democratic Republic of Congo.
There were a lot of issues with infrastructure in the country.
I had always imagined me coming to the U.S. for college to major in civil engineering.
My name is Samuel Makisikala, and I'm graduating from Pasadena City College.
When I arrived, I was excited to meet new people and make new friends.
But then COVID hit.
Everything was online.
I didn't know anybody here.
I was lonely and homesick.
I felt like giving up.
But my sister told me, you gotta be the change you want to see.
I was waking up at 3:00 AM to go to work.
Then I would come home to take my online classes.
It was physically and mentally exhausting.
But now, I'm here.
I could not have done it without my sister's support.
I am proud to celebrate this milestone,...
...and I'm continuing to pursue my purpose to make a difference.